okay hi everyone we are here to do a
language design review getting ready for
version 13.3 and we have a collection of
things here uh supposedly related to
astronomy and geography but I see we
have at first around
um right okay
yeah
so we already talked about these in a
previous meeting didn't we yes um at
least two times before and so
effectively we agreed on what to do but
there were a couple of coefficients
uh that to choose and this is the moment
where we where we decide what truth is
so to speak with respect to numbers it's
a heuristic choice and and we just have
to make a choice so I have it's very
similar to what we discussed last time
with a with a variation and I want to
explain the evaluation
so yeah if you do evaluate this should
work in the
in the X column
okay so these
stayed unevaluated before and now they
give a consistent uh answer and it
should be always the first to true the
middle three true or the final two two
one
A1 is less than A2 yes if that is true
then the next one should also be true
because it's less or equal
yes
then the middle three are together
because if they are equal they they all
give true all the middle three there's
last three here no the meal three
they're five so the middle three the
second the third and the fourth
go together
right
yes and the last two go together
well except they don't in this case not
in this case I mean giving true
either the first to give true or the
middle three give true or the last two
gift true and the other and the others
so in other words they're either it's
either ordered with A1 less than A2 in
some sense
or they are consistent with being equal
or further around okay I got it exactly
yes I'm just saying this because for
example for intervals this doesn't
happen
and so yeah so for this
object for around this will always
happen
okay they never stay unevaluated and
they always give true or false with that
rule okay
is the same as four numbers okay so the
next one shows that this is fast it's
within another uh sorry with a factor
three of what numbers do so it's very
fast
okay so this shows
that so if I say that thing is greater
than zero
then it's gonna come out true yes
so this is consistently this the 0.50 is
consistently larger than 0.14 there is a
factor square root there of margin of
two sorry and and yeah in this case it's
but if I say something like a round of
0.5 comma two and now I say percent
greater than zero
like something now we cannot claim it's
clearly
true
right
so if I figure out
you know if I do the obvious thing
and I say plot
Bool
of around
D comma
let's say zero comma two
what is Rule
are doing oh perhaps you have to do
around greater than zero you want a
predicate yeah yeah right right it wants
to say greater than zero
cool asaurus
right so where that jump happens is the
discussion to be had right by the way
this is a nice picture to put in the
documentation absolutely yep yep yeah I
really like it the
um
okay this is an interesting Moment of
Truth so to speak so it really mean
mostly true
this weird
that I can
you know drive down the asymptote
so that's what we want
I think
I think if we plot it then we don't know
anything about it whether it's an
asymptote or yeah okay fine fine fine
okay but so in fact now look at this
first time I've ever used this feature
0.354 so if I do this
I'm going to be able to see the
ah 0.707 I recognize that
that's that's one Sigma in some way is
that right
it's effective square root of 2 divided
by two okay one over square root of two
okay oh yeah because okay let's see why
um
um so yes so in this case you can see if
you evaluate those functions you can see
the two distributions and so they are
clearly separated
yes
yeah but right but I mean in the case at
the marginal case the imaginary case is
just below if you go to the next
paragraph you see the marginal case
so these you see so we have Sigma 1 0.1
so I've tried to to have here the
simplest case Sigma 0.1 in both cases so
2 Sigma
would be just moving 1.2
and that's what that's where the I have
a question in the fraction Theory that's
kind of the Rayleigh Criterion and so on
is this at all related to that
I don't remember enough about that to
sing I can't do it really Criterion is
is when when you can distinguish to
um
you know it's the thing that leads to
uh
see what I've got this uh could we find
yeah
um
okay this is a random web page about
really criteria
two images are just resolvable in the
center of the diffraction pattern of one
is directly over the first minimum of
that fashion pattern or the other that's
why it's the zeros of the uh the area
yep
so this is not related to that because
this is assuming gaussian distribution
so this is a different
distinguishability Criterion but but you
see the Border case which is in the in
the picture in the lower part of your
notebook the minimum of the yellow curve
Falls in a pretty loud point of the
other curve
minimum here what do you mean no no if
you go to the maximum of the yellow
curve yeah that point is has a small
value of the blue curve
sure
which which I think is one of one reason
why we can say it's already clearly
separated
yeah yeah right right okay
of the two curves
exactly
so the other time we discussed about
this we were always using area arguments
and so
you see there is the overlapping
function there
and so these border case has around 30
something percent of overlapping
this is plot range Ro
let's say zero to five or something or
ten
why am I seeing this I don't understand
this
do I want the
oh gosh what am I trying to see
this isn't a useful plot
um
well let's see is that is it and maybe
I'm just making this up but but um
uh
perhaps if you do a lock plot we will
understand it better
is this relevant
I think that might be relevant yeah the
transition is is happening more or less
at the place where we have the
the transition ourselves right right so
that this plot is somewhat revealing
because this is basically showing
there's a there's a region of
uncertainty which is when it isn't
really close to one or really close to
minus one
and where are we making the cutoff
in this case it is two Sigma so Sigma
0.1 for both
2 is 0.2 so it will be at 1.2
by the way when I Mouse to this point on
the axis I'm not thrilled with the fact
that I'm getting the nearest point on a
curve there
somewhere So eventually we go away from
we're not showing any
I I'd like to make a make a claim so to
speak for Roger who's probably the only
representative of that group
here
um
that something different might happen on
the axis that we might have something
where you can go along the axis and find
where on the curve do you hit if you're
at that point in the axis
I mean there's different there are
things that that use is called I think
it's called vertical line or X line
which does just that that is a different
different mode okay but I wonder whether
we should have a combined mode where you
if you're on the axis if you're sitting
on the axis you get one of those and if
you're sitting on the curb you get one
of these
I'd like to raise that possibility
let's bring it up when we meet next
which is Monday I think okay
um
okay by the way the two minute digits
here but we already knew that right
yeah
okay
um Okay so
I mean it seems to me that what you're
doing is sensible here
so there is this variable at the end
which controls this number
I mean if we've changed the then the
value of that variable
then this boundary will move
what does the two mean two Sigma two
Sigma
I think this looks fine I mean I mean is
that name of that variable did we
already discussed that name the name we
didn't discuss we discussed the value
and and that's the number we agreed
I don't think that name is right because
confidence will be a confidence level
and this is a sigma number
yep
um
okay statistics moment I mean in in you
know what would be
uh
okay what is this number this number is
the number of standard deviations
at which
what is the right thing to say out which
it's deemed
around the toronts are different
right okay
um
well maybe it's a resolution something
like it's around
um
I don't know that's not very good we
have the percent of equal tolerance I
was trying to avoid using tolerance
because this is a slightly different
concept but it's a good word
well maybe there's tolerance ratio
which kind of suggests that something
slightly different is going on
perhaps the presence of Iran at the
beginning is is good enough to
disambiguate and we call this around
equal tolerance
if you just see that that name it's very
hard to know what the heck it is
actually you can never know what
tolerance means it's different
everywhere
I see
I would prefer to call it a tolerance
ratio
because I feel like that because what it
really is is the ratio to the uh you
know to the delta
I mean and I would skip the word equal
there I would just call it a round
tolerance ratio
well the that word is there because
there is a second parameter in the next
section
which is the one we might remove so so
before you remove that equal let's have
a look at that one okay so so I think
what we saw is for comparisons so less
equal less equal Etc so now we will deal
with numerical order and min max
so now I I've introduced this private
function called render marrow that's not
in system it's just in the
initialization cell
to play with random cases
okay so so look at this list random and
Rod so we create 20 random rounds
and then we do numerical sort of that
list yep
so notice how for example the last two
do not seem correctly sorted hold on let
me let me just take this
and let me do a list plot of that
by the way that's a good picture to show
in the documentation I think
the problem here is that for example the
first three clearly look very similar
and they are considered equal that's why
I have the next line with the zeros so
the zeros mean that the first pair are
equal the second pair are equal
Etc
uh-huh
now the problem is that it looks strange
for example that the last two do not
seem sorted you see we get
9.78 before 9.7
and so these this is something that is
called drifting and which makes the
solution non-unique
and I think since the last time we
discussed I understood a comment from
Mark saying that in his opinion
numerical order should have no tolerance
whatsoever
so it should just operate based on the
base number the center number exactly
and so right now I'm using 0.5 Sigma we
agreed on a very small tolerance but
having something but now I suggest we
just go to zero to avoid this problem
and and if you scroll down you see how
to change it and how it will look better
so see we changed the 0.5 to 0. and then
we do numerical sort again
and now now things look
consistently increasing
yeah even though now in numerical order
and less than don't agree
but that happens already with numbers
equal historians numerical order has no
tolerance
is sensible
but maybe we should have a parameter
here
um
we can keep this parameter right they
around all their confidence
it's just Zero by default if somebody
wants to increase it they can
if somebody complains I think if
somebody complains and they change it
they'll just blow up everything they're
doing I think it's it's kind of like a
doomed idea
I mean I think we should just decide you
know we can keep it as a system
um
as a you know system variable
I mean I'm not proposing to move any of
these two variables to system at all
like in equal tolerances internal
well then have a good well okay then
don't even have
is an internal variable or is it a
system option
it's an internal variable
again like equal tolerance
then around equal to around
what did we say around tolerance ratio
yep
if we don't have the other one then we
don't need the equal here
you know what if it's going to be an
internal thing let's just call it around
equal tolerance variable and around
order tolerance ratio
and have them both and set one to two
and the other to zero
sounds good
okay
and then that section just shows that we
can do the same thing with numbers with
quantities with asymmetric cases
including quantities of different units
cool all cases work
you know I have a question when we have
a unit
are there in fact yet units and perhaps
there should be that are around
well I mean looks with uncertainty in
their yeah
we have units that have
fundamental values that are intervals
okay but I don't well like the mass of
the electron is only you know known to a
certain number of digits yeah and those
we typically represent with Precision
rather than
okay
which doesn't seem foolish yeah it's
maybe a question for Michael uh that
yeah we should raise that question now
that a round is really working well
we should raise that question
of whether we should for example redo
various kinds of particle masses and so
on using using the fact that they can
really be around
okay next item
date granularity option
yep so we introduced this in 13-2 when
we needed it for random date but it was
pretty much exclusive to random date and
random time we've propagated out to the
containers data object time object data
interval and also the functions that
construct State objects
to me
not further comment on that yep and then
we just while we were at it we basically
standardized some of those Constructors
like from absolute time didn't handle
all the options date object did support
so we've propagated those out elsewhere
good
this is also going to be useful in Astro
because we had some functions
uh reporting minute gun reality with
these users will be able to specify
which granularity
we haven't done it yet but but this will
be very useful in astroto
research technology for what sorry for
these these options having functions
like Sunrise users might want to get
minutes in return
and as results rather than instance for
example
yep
good
okay sorry yeah
I was raising the question of uh in some
completely different meeting of the
server side updates needed to get
geographs
which I'd really like to see us get
uh
and also vector graphics you know faster
vector graphics
yes so for for geograph do you mean
beyond the function and geograph plot
yeah I mean I mean the the street
Network
the long discussed Street network of the
city
as as a graph or orthographics
no it's a graph I mean being able to
being if you want to do routing right
you need to know
you know you need to know what the
I mean I think the default graph we
should get should have
um vertex coordinates that correspond to
the geocoordinates of the streets
by default so what you see is kind of a
shadow of what's in the um
uh
you know of what's on the ground so to
speak
but then you can compute and each Edge
should be have an annotation that's the
name of the street and things like this
and potentially the length of the street
um and then you know you can start
Computing routing and so on
so the travel directions data is doing
that in the Geo server I know that I
know that I know that but I'm saying
let's expose the graph
I think it'll be very useful I think
people will find it very interesting
yep yep
okay okay so so one function that we
have been working
on this and this cycle is here within
queue to make it uh better and also more
powerful and inputs taking the
opposition arrays
Etc so all these changes are server side
and they haven't been propagated to
production but they will be in a few
weeks for 13 three good
yeah so this function is getting better
and then something I wanted to mention
is is Halloween which hasn't been done
by this team but by the graphics uh
and and it looks really nice
it we we requested this for labels
but in the end
um this turned out to be very useful
also for
for boundaries yeah so so listen let's
talk about this for a bit because those
numbers there are very weird
right maybe we need a string name you
know maybe we need some string styles
for haloing that do useful things I
don't even remember what the minus two
and minus eight I mean they have to do
with whether where the Halo goes
it's a Halo it's it's meaning they're
going towards the Interior right so the
the border of the US is being hallowed
to towards the interior not towards the
exterior no I understand that but what
is the minus two the minus two is is
what does that mean minus two to minus
eight
so these are these um pixels that we
have solid Halloween and then eight
pixels of blurred progressively blurred
hello
okay is it really right that those two
things are separate arguments rather
than in some kind of list
that would be a question for them
I haven't really looked at that we can
bring it up look at it let's bring that
up because I think that
but but to me
you know this is magnificent but I don't
want to have to remember 0.3 minus two
minus eight you know all this kind of
stuff yeah
um for old I care there they probably
already are
string names and if not we should should
answer
we we've added string names for all the
other ones so I'm just
yeah okay
well I mean
you know haloing of quotes in a Halo or
something
or inner border outer border
or
um
haloing in haloing out
inside outside
no
it could be um
uh what would you call an inside padding
it's not quite padding what is it
wrapping inside what is the right term
for this it's kind of like a inside
coating
you know what I'm saying
I mean this this clearly only uh applies
to solids 2D solids
otherwise there is no insight
yeah fair enough
well anyway we need some string names
and this is the right group to talk
about the set
um
so the the main application for us is is
Halloween and we're in the process of
um
yeah the fact that we can now see this
is is great it's going to be very useful
yep I agree with you did you consult
with design yet on what the best way to
do this is because this aspect of this
don't look quite right
the numbers I chose just one there so
the numbers need to be fine-tuned yes
but but this is the this is this was the
original purpose of requesting hello
which is very easy I understand so but I
would just recommend working with design
because like that thing there ends up
because we kind of speed up these tiles
what are we doing to speed up the tile
so we are working on with Francisco on
three things one is a synchronous
downloads of the tiles right now we are
using downloading the the files second
in order for the CDN to accept so many
tiles we group them in in what we call
Meta tiles of eight by eight and so we
have to download enormous amount of data
and sometimes this is about one time
maybe we should change the way the CDN
works well Francisco is saying that if
we do this in the jio server ourselves
like we had the the image Styles we have
more control and this can be made faster
so that's an idea we have to explore and
then a Third Avenue wait a minute
there's no way we'll get we'll be faster
than CDR
but if there's something wrong with our
CDN setup that causes us to only have a
certain number of tiles we should just
fix the CDN setup
okay well so when we added this for the
first time we were told not to add too
many okay I don't know why because
because we probably have some contract
for a certain number of things in the
CDN but let's figure out how to change
that and I also suspect that if we look
at the tiling in different parts of the
earth there are some places where the
tiles you know are very detailed and
somewhere they're not
yes
that happens yeah yeah so we should
figure this out let's get more
sophisticated about that I mean the fact
that we're doing eight that that that
feels like the the big killer is this
Mega tiles
you know yeah but there's other stuff
too like those tiles come with
a bunch of place names that we're never
going to use okay so fine so let's let's
clean those tiles for God's sake we
really need to get this for this version
we really need to get this sped up yep
okay we need to sort of change I mean I
think that the problem is in in
Latin America we don't get consistent
work on this
oh let's talk to Johan about it yeah
yeah we need to make this happen I mean
and if you need to have a specific
meeting with me to go over this issue
please set that up
all right okay let's March this one you
know
explicitly to the end
why didn't this work
that is strange I mean I evaluated it in
today's
Mexican well maybe maybe my channel is
out of date
okay
yep yeah I I wasn't I think this was
merged yesterday precisely so it may
have been the well I may be a bad day
yeah it could be but yeah it does work I
checked it today okay I'm just saying
please consult with design about precise
parameters and maybe maybe helloing
parameters that depend on the size of
the text and so on because some of those
things were starting to look like those
kind of 1950s you know
uh yes right things
okay we'll do
um
okay Astro
okay so the first thing is something
that Jeff mostly has done and it is to
update all our 16 functions to now use
our new technology which is faster and
more precise so are you serious so I can
say the sunrise on how do I do this on
on
to get this fixed of these these rafts
this is something I don't know who's
project managing here but I just want to
make sure we track over the next who is
doing project management here hi I'm
Marcy okay so this business I don't know
whether you were in the meeting where we
talked about escaping rafts where I move
my mouse down the raft disappears but
this is yet another example of that
and I kind of want to make sure
absolutely without fails gets fixed
understood
okay all right so anyway oh Christ I you
know how do I get to this now
okay bye
all right location spec
so if I say
taking its time it's not showing me any
download up
why did it take so long to start there
the first time there is a there's an
English initialization time of um
of yes
if you evaluate it again for a different
time a different place it would be much
faster
okay question question
I mean clearly there's a relativistic
issue here
I mean I hate to be Persnickety about
that
but
is this you know there's a spacecraft on
you know IO or something and it's about
to see the sunrise
um
is this the time at which the light
signal would reach Earth
because that's probably the most useful
thing to give it there rather than the
some kind of weird local time that's
back computed since we're experiencing
it from IO so to speak oh okay so we
can't do it from the moon that's got to
be a Geo position
IO is just an entity it's not a no
specific location you gotta have a
horizon in order to measure Sunrise okay
so before I say Geo position zero zero
on iO I I mean we also need to have an
orientation model and for some small
moons sometimes we don't have them
okay but it seems for this one we do
so
so coming back to
to
a question yep about time so what we do
is that we use this
time that is globally defined on the
whole solar system
and so we are using time the value that
would be measured on Earth but we apply
this to a space like hypersurfaces
across the whole solar system
there is a very well
defined notion it's called the bcrs
reference system
and this defines instance the
simultaneity
surfaces across the solar system
okay so let me just understand
there's a spacecraft on iO we're about
to get a photograph of this beautiful
sunrise
does this tell us when we'll get the
photograph or does this bat correct
is this a time when we will get that
photograph yes so this is taking into
account the fact that IO is farther from
the Sun than the Earth so that's taken
into account
yeah this is a precise instant that
makes sense
to say in at this instance from IO you
see the solar the sunrise
okay but let me walk through my question
again okay spacecraft is transmitting
pictures we've got a real-time feed from
the spacecraft.io yep and at some moment
you know the people in the mission
control for the spacecraft are all
excited because they're about to see the
sunrise does this tell us that time or
not
I understood yes but not transmitting
them back
no no no not transmitting the back going
back to IO different story
but I'm asking is this the time
that the people in the control room will
see the sunrise
it's a time at which people at IO would
see the sunrise yeah in the spacecraft
exactly
okay but but it's also useful then
to ask
I mean we also want the delayed time in
other words the time
so this is VCRs coordinate system but
I'm asking for a different coordinate
system one that is
where the simultaneity surface
says
which are light cones basically going
back from the Earth
right that operation is not being done
here so there is no participation of the
Earth in this computation there is
participation of the position of the sun
and the position of Ayo I see I see
because this coordinate system is global
to the solar system exactly
okay I argue that we should have an
option here because I think this is
fairly confusing
and I think we should have an option
that says I mean you've already defined
a bunch of these things about when
yeah it would be fairly easy to compute
like it would be I know in a secondary
transmission
from IO to the Earth
yes
yeah so I mean what would that be is
there a duration computation that I
could do to get to that
I mean we can do it manually by saying
for example
when does the
Earth c i o at this time something like
that
but but of course we have to go to Astra
position we would have to say after
position of IO
the outcome of that date
then saying observing from I don't know
from Champagne at that time
yeah and that's that type of thing and
this would give us the distance
and that sort of thing
so I claim there's another argument then
to Sunrise which is the observing
position
I I think I see your idea it's not just
Sunrise it's like
after you have observed this transmit
the signal somewhere else
yeah exactly
so given any scissorgy or whatever any
of these things right any of these
events
what we're saying is
that thing sunrise at IO
is an event in space-time
and the issue is at what point
you know
the event that is the thing entering the
light entering the observer's eye is
another event
that is time like separated from that
first event
and the question is what's the time that
elapses on that time like Edge so to
speak
no what's mostly no no because in those
two cases the Earth is not entering the
game so this event is the event at which
the Observer
in IO
on iO on the surface of IO is seeing the
light being uh appearing for the first
of all right yep no I understand it so
then I'm asking I I said it wrong in
terms of how that I'm asking
you know
like
you know we could have a thing that's
saying Observer location arrow and then
champagne or whatever
and then this would compute
when that space-time event
will arrive in the time system
of Will and right based on light pulse
at that location of the Observer
I would I would claim that the Observer
is still on iO is the Observer observing
the sunrise we could have an option
saying rate rank Smith 2 or something
like that
well no I mean the Observer
I see I see I see I see your point is
that the Observer the photons coming
from the Sun are arriving at i o in fact
it turned into an electrical signal you
know electric a radio signal is a
different story
exactly the retransmission of the event
which may happen with whatever
wavelength
it's a different
physical process
yeah it is
well maybe it should be
what should it be called
um
final observation location
perhaps the first argument could be an
arrow so we have like two positions
potentially in two different planets the
first one is the one observer in the Sun
the second one is receiving
yeah that makes sense
that makes sense
will that work for others but other this
is a city isn't it or is it not I
remember that is it it is yeah
it's an alignment of
astronomical objects
um
it is one of the events I mean the next
function is a generalization of this
function we are discussing and and then
there will be other generalizations
eventually we should have a powerful
financial event that can find all sorts
of
alignments or quotations transits
Solstice disease there are so many
things to compute
right
okay let's look at this next one here
okay I could have a slightly less ornate
Observer
yes we had discussed with her
well there should be whether it makes
sense that it's working and that he is
working no it makes no sense at all
um
okay so this is the analyzation of us
sorry sunrise sunset to any object
observe from anywhere
cool
and now there are two main differences
with respect to the traditional
functions one is this idea which we are
not very sure about of returning both
the sets and the Rises together
it's useful because they are computed
together so it's a bit of a loss of time
to compute them separately
but on the other hand then it becomes
clunky to use the information because
you have to do extraction somehow
yeah well you could also return
a list of all the Rises and all the sets
which seems more useful because you're
probably going to want one of them
yeah I don't know that's not I mean they
they have to intersperse correct exactly
they will alternate
but it it's not clear which one starts
yeah I understand
except in the far northern hemisphere
right so that that that's this example
you see we compute quickly like 300
Rises and sets
and they would plot them separately but
just we have to do this group by
and we see the gap of the summer there
is nothing no rice no set during the
summer
that's very cool
I don't know why those are not aligned
um okay
you know I feel like
the the problem is that there are things
that have a beginning and an end
But Rising and setting aren't quite like
that it's not like because you could
start with a set for example
right
I see what you mean unless we could
laugh I'm sorry oh it's always rise set
and if you inter intersect over the
first one you know you say give me all
the rise set pairs
where those intervals lie between this
and this
I see
so we've been focusing on altitude is
positive rather than altitude is zero
perhaps yes the intervals
um
in which case we could say you know
visible times or something
but let's see how we would use this
again
uh
by the way just Sunset deal with this
listed thing if I say sunset for a month
does it does it do the right thing so
sunset and sunrise continue the old idea
of give me the next
so they return only one and it's the
next one which may jump over the whole
summer
yeah I understand
but then maybe we should we should have
times at the end of this name
um
but maybe we don't need Astra maybe we
say rise set times
okay but but the main thing is what's
going to be useful
and the default case presumably here is
from here and next ones
today
as defined at your
location your dollar time zone okay
as opposed to next one exactly how could
you get next one
you have to go on a hunt through the
summer through the winter whatever right
so there are advantages and
disadvantages if if your focus is on
next one you have to estimate
which for the general case I think it's
an advantage because imagine that
something that rotates super super
slowly with the Earth we only have an
idea how how it does rotate
but with something else if we just say
the next we may be hunting for a long
time
well if the user always has to specify a
a Time window the thing is controlled
well so we're having to hunt we don't
have a way of computing where we Auto
hunt so to speak yes
we sort of irreducibly hunt we can't
jump ahead and just invert the
astronomical formula basically
I would be okay with with having the
third argument taking the string next or
previous and then we do the same thing
yeah yeah
okay let's think about how we do this I
really don't like the the string rise
set there I also have a question when we
have other astronomical events where we
have a
you know will there be a different set
of
um
yeah yes I think I see what you want
this was actually the motivation for
these strings imagine a function find us
through event
from here on this month and we return
everything that is interesting that
month yeah I kind of think that that
should be more like some kind of entity
construct
of the rise of this over that type thing
if we're going to do that
I see
um
um oh boy
what analogies do we have to this at all
we have things returning intervals
Roger do you have any comments here yeah
I mean this looks to me like an event
series
so the future of event series
um where Cloud categorical data yeah
exactly
and I could imagine that one might want
to store more I mean maybe not for Rice
there maybe isn't more to store but an
event could have more information like
an earthquake you might know more about
it then
then it had like its size or something
yeah
or in the Lim you know event is in the
eye of the beholder I guess
you know so really complex event can be
just an event but then you might want
more information and I think
astronomical events too can be
complicated events right there's more
information you might kind of want from
them yeah sure for an eclipse it could
be how big is the eclipse and so on
right
well so you're saying a rice set event
series is the thing that we're most
likely to
I think that this will fit really nicely
with event series and tabular above
actually where you can then do
subsequent analysis
of different kinds
all right well
then the question is is that a string or
is it an entity or what the heck is it
that second argument
and I mean there's an argument okay so
here's a here's a claim astronomical
event type as entities
seems like a reasonable thing to do an
eclipse a solstice or this or that or
the other
yeah it would have to be relatively
Dynamic I mean you got eclipses and then
is solar eclipse a separate type of
event or is it
no an eclipse is
between A and B I mean if you say
well Eclipse has three things involved
right
yes I mean it's an eclipse of of the Sun
by a right
it's a type of occultation
something's occulting something else
right
okay
so I hadn't thought of that I mean if In
These Fine Master events would we be
reporting eclipses seen from Mars
well there aren't real eclipses because
those moons are very small
actually Phobos they've actually had
pictures from one of the Rovers where
the big mood moved in front of the sun
it didn't cover the Sun but it was a
significant portion of it covers like 60
of it or something like that
there is a very impressive video about
it
yeah well so but that's an occultation
rather than what we would normally call
on Eclipse I mean eclipse is specific
isn't it to the earth and the and the
Moon being as big as the Sun from the
Earth
am I not correct
I don't know if an eclipse is
specifically defined to be from Earth it
might be I don't know
I think eclipse means I mean maybe there
are moons of Saturn or something that
are big enough given the size of the sun
at that distance that they eclipse the
Sun
mm-hmm
I mean our own Moon doesn't always
totally cover the sun you know it's uh
you can have a an annular Eclipse where
the Moon is far enough away at the time
that it you still have a ring that's not
visible
yeah
just
we should have seen it earlier
and you know what the moon was closer to
the Earth
the dinosaurs probably didn't have any
did the dinosaurs have any other
eclipses I bet they didn't
um sort of reminds me of an event log
like a server log
yes that's true yep
I favor having astronomical event types
as entities
or but already for this another
possibility would be to break this
function into astral rise and Astro set
following sunrise and sunset and they
have in the future find us Revenge
following that
because I'm not sure we can create a
domain in
in the time we have 4133
all right but we can uh the yeah the
release time of alpha is like a month
and it requires some thought as to you
can't just have entities you gotta have
properties too what are the properties
of these entities
I gotta run but I know you guys will
solve it
bye see you okay bye
well so Astro rise time Astro set time
and why did you want time if sunrise and
sunset do not have time because sunrise
and sunset of things I've always heard
of
astral rise sounds like some kind of
form of you know baking something rather
I mean it just
um
it seems a bit crazy to have two
functions for this
we could perhaps have these things
initially and then once we get there
entities
which is the entities
well it'll break any code
because you've got to be able to test
for those strings
so I have examples further than what I
find myself doing is just doing a
replacement of the dates by functions of
the dates
yeah I think the next one
here for example
so this is explaining that
rising and setting are defined by the
Upper Limb touching the horizon
acute
all right
it's cranky
okay let's think about what happens with
what can we do with associations
having the date SAS keys
I'm not sure that helps us I mean
the basic point is
oh boy
so that that's the same thing with Venus
and so showing how very precise this is
because Venus is an arc second in size
or something like that
a few accidents that's cute
so it's possible to see for example how
how long does it take for Venus to cross
the Horizon from from the top limb to
the bottom limb yeah right
very cool
okay when are we going to get rid of
that stupid telescope I thought we'd
gotten rid of that did we not get rid of
that not in the previous release and and
then we just yeah we didn't consider it
but we didn't get rid of it
the holder scope or just the the couple
or I don't know how to call it it's too
cutesy we please get a more sensible
looking icon that doesn't look like it's
a play school thing
okay
um
okay what are we gonna do with this
ah okay
I mean two clear possibilities are
breaking the function into the other is
postponing the function
until we have the
more more events I mean we can compute
things like Eclipse sorry
um Source this is an equinoxes
faces of the Moon that has been praised
by a user well okay here's another
possibility
another possibility would be
we insist that the results are rise set
and
put them in pairs
and if the first one
is a
is out of range
that first list is just a single from
list
now is that right can we do that yes we
can do that if it's a
no no because we could have an automatic
for example the ones that are outside
either we try to hunt for them
or we put their automatic or
Nan or something
oh we just don't have that we have a
list of a shorter length
but so in general
for manipulation it would be complicated
to do all two or one things like that
yeah okay
we could just hunt we know it will
happen sometime in there we may have to
cross the summer but
stop
it's not very general with respect to
other astronomical events though
that's true
it also bothers me that it's set this
means something utterly different
um
we could have an analogy with visibility
because this is when something is above
the horizon
yes
and well how would that work
Astra visible
interval Center Master visible
okay
periods
what is it called geovisible region
It's A Primitive yeah right
extra visible times
so imagine for example that we were
designing the function to get solstices
and equinoxes
which I think naturally would take a
year
yes
and so it would be again something that
would return groups of four
and we would have a similar problem
um
okay what about
um what about this
just take it
okay so let's say this is this
and now let's uh want to plot
let's say I make that into a data set
that's quite beautiful
now let's say I want to say
uh how do I pick up I mean I could
certainly do cases but that's kind of
ugly
cases of
data comma
ankle bracket rise Arrow X blank
are perfectly reasonable
um
I do think though that the way
this thing should have another argument
where you can say quotes rise
to pick out only the risers
I see
why would it go in here
the last two arguments are just to have
this a bit more powerful
the alpha is to say I'm not interested
at zero but at -6 degrees and for
example we can then compute Twilight
moments
that's cool
and the final one I was going to ask you
what do you think about this word limb
it's fine
it's not astronomical word
okay this is that I know for example
Roger said it sounds very strange to
call this a limp but it's still at the
standard yeah stranded and I certainly
heard of it
well okay so where could we put this in
we could use the arrow notation that
we're using in our functions in the
first argument so Astro Arrow
rice Astro are all
yeah that's reasonable because it makes
sense it's that thing that is rising or
setting I was wondering if there was an
obvious Arrow Place
we could generalize properties that you
may be interested in you know what's the
actual
um
yeah for example yep
yes we can
that would be nice
well then maybe we should say set time
and Rise time set as news rise azimuth
as those as those um
so
okay
okay how difficult is it I mean the fact
okay you can avoid using cases by just
using arrow set time then you just I'm
never going to get
those things
actually you know what you could get
here in principle you could get set time
comma and then set Azimuth error
whatever
see what I'm saying yeah their
Association could have several things
right
I use a lot all for example and then you
report all you can you know I know but
that that's
all in two Dimensions both both the
Rises and the sets
and the
uh
you know and the return the Azimuth as
well as the time
um
how do we deal with that that point
that it's both rise set and its time you
know Azimuth time
I mean we could rather grotesquely
have this concept of
you know all being
automatic being
rise set all being everything and then
we could do things like
yeah set time set has moved and those
two will be clustered together
and if you say set time rise Azimuth
you'll get rather strange results
have the association of having
event type goes to Rice time
use
and that each Association is a is an
event
this will be similar to Technologies for
example when we say Tech largest
list Arrow all it will be reporting
things about each individual element
yeah okay
fair enough I mean Time Event
I kind of like that event Arrow time
Arrow
and this will fit the Rogers event
series nicely
fine
okay
seems reasonable to me
nice functionality
the alpha can be one of those civil
nautical astronomical yep
uh yes exactly they have standard
definitions minus six minus 12 of minus
sitting
okay and this is the final part
which has been the main part in this
asterisk icon even though it's not yet
just exposed this is the major part of
the next
thing coming no or for orbits so the
idea here as I was explaining the LD
meeting the other day you have that to
describe the position of an object that
is orbiting rather than describing
trying to simulate or trying to to model
the the fast
you just you just give it you just say
the orbital parameters very slowly these
are the orbital parameters and the
things spinning around within those
social parameters
exactly yep so this function computes
quickly all these multiple parameters of
orbits
and then it can report them in various
times in better forms with quantities
without them in lists Etc
and it uses different sources you can
use our high Precision data or the
approximated data that we have in
several forms
okay are you planning on the angles
coming back in radians
this should be configurable okay
we have I mean that's another discussion
we should have that we have the same
problem with with us to position itself
the properties should they be given
quantities or numbers and if quantities
in which units Etc
I think it would be nice to have a
general notation
yes to specify I want this as in these
units
well it's like unit Converse except that
it's a more General it's a it's a local
form of unit convert exactly yep
don't we have Target units isn't that a
isn't that a thing in thermodynamic data
for example some of the visualization
functions they have that
Target units yep yeah
well then that's what we should use
plus I'm misremembering but I'm pretty
sure I remember seeing that yeah okay
but
well imagine something like you as a
position that you can report distances
and goals
multiple things
so how do we know which we say Target
units and then you give it a list of
units and whichever unit it'll only
you know if it says radians minutes
it's not argument it's minutes right
radians and minutes angles and radians
and time and Mass I see
and we might give single strings for you
know there's a if there's a standard
convention which there may not be
I see
I think I was looking for something that
I could wrap around each property so
that this it would be more local like I
want this in Arc seconds but that other
one in degrees
I see
oh boy that's a discussion with Michael
and so on because that's something we
could imagine using just like we have
dated exactly
very general I just how wonder how often
you're going to want to mix units of the
same
physical quantity
um
well no I'm I understand I mean why not
be able to say
something like
it's a nice idea I mean being able to
get a sort of a immediate result of the
boiling temperature of water in
Fahrenheit
right so that you don't have to go
through an intermediate
value just to convert it again
yes
um
and it's company like unit output of
property comma then the unit
yeah
we should talk to Michael about it I
mean it could possibly of course will be
unit convert I mean could be wrapped
there maybe that's not a very good idea
it takes one argument to convert the
base
oh yeah okay
anyway so I just wanted to show you this
functionality which already works pretty
well and it reports a ton of stuff
and then below there is there are
examples
of what's going on here so we have this
what is called the oscillating or
instantaneous orbital Elements which are
like you approximate an orbit
to to uh to a small fraction of the
orbit around the a given point in time
mm-hmm but that thing is very much
affected by I don't know the Earth for
example the Earth is going up and down
because of the moon like thousands of
kilometers yep and so the orbit of the
earth is changing quite a lot
continuously so the average orbit around
the the sun is this sort of yellow line
there which is what is called the
secular orbital elements
or average or means
and so we have now formulas to compute
those fast and
okay but I mean in this thing where
you're giving the orbital elements
for the Earth
you're saying there's an average orbital
element from 2000 to 2030.
and that wouldn't get all the Wiggles
right but you would go in and say I want
to compute the sort of element for every
month
and that which will be kind of silly in
this case because by that point oh in
other words the orbital elements are
useful when the thing can you know go
around its orbit many times before
there's a substantial change of these
parameters
that correct
um well I would say ideally we had
formulas for the exact orbital elements
we would convert those exact orbital
elements in into exact positions and
velocities
but that's very difficult so what we can
do is to approximate them
and then we get a progressively Better
or Worse depending on Direction You Go
progressively worse approximations to
the positions and velocities
and so what this formulas give are like
smaller models so that we don't have to
download tons of data
and they approximate the orbital
elements as you are seeing here but this
this approximation is still quite good
because you see the numbers are very
small on the
yeah are very close
on the y-axis
yep so we may be making errors of one
part in 10 000 or something yeah yeah
okay so wait a minute so this is not yet
this functionality is not yet enabled in
13 3 is that correct exactly
but this will be a major piece of the
orbits functionality for 14.
right and so you'll be able to give
these These are these the two line
elements the thing that you're showing
here exactly
two line elements are alternative ways
of expressing disorder elements
okay
so we'll be able we'll have an export
form to some sort of Standard tle
Version
and so for any given you know it's like
find me that satellite okay here it's
tlees
well
here we have the the two directions
given the tle we can find this position
now to get the tle we need to consult
databases out there things like that
it's not information yeah I know but
isn't there a format that is just like
I've seen these theories they're quite
short yep yep
I've never seen I've never seen the ones
that you're talking about referred to
other than Earth satellites I mean maybe
they're relevant I just oh no no no it's
just a satellite yeah
but so
I'm just saying there are presumably
random satellite is launched there are
tles that are you know that are known by
somebody for that satellite we should be
able to import those formats
well good this looks great
I mean I'm I'm um
and then presumably we can just give
you know for any given satellite we can
get it to tle it's it's
orbital elements
then
I mean presumably we can compute
weird stuff like that which is not so
irrelevant like the rise of well clearly
we can compute the rise of such a
satellite which we can already do can we
compute that not in the language right
the rise of such and such satellite from
a given location
do we have that functionality in
Satellite in the satellite it'll yeah we
can tell you for the current tle for the
date you've specified when it will next
rise yes how do we do that how do you
get that
um
I don't know because I didn't Implement
that I think that's left over from Todd
Roland's old stuff
but I think Stephen is asking for the
property what's the property data I
think it's just called rise time
that may be because it's far enough it
only looks a certain amount of time
ahead
no avoid timeouts but
um let me verify that it's called rise
time I could be wrong
I think it's called Next rise or
something
oh
well in any case it is computable if we
know the orbit of course it is computer
huh
that's really weird
and what happens for a geostationary
satellite
well it's I think for example if is
if to asteroid set we ask when is
Polaris going to rise and set if we just
return an empty list
because it knows it's a compiler
I see
but we don't know if there was a
southern Polaris
we wouldn't know from that whether it's
always up or always down
exactly yeah
it could be computer I mean it could be
another property
that is the right property Name by the
way I verified that it's just spacecraft
um
could try um
I don't know spot four that's right
why does not work for the other stuff
probably because the algorithm that
looks ahead it's going to be a while
before we have one visible from your
location and it basically it it can't
spend an infinite amount of time looking
ahead in time for when the next thing is
going to happen so it basically has a
timeout basically for all intents and
purposes
so
from your location it's going to be
quite some time before ISS is visible so
it's not going to rise from your
location and I'm looking almost an alpha
and it says where it currently is
and I see as it as it wiggle you know as
it kind of goes around the Earth
it's a low earth orbit satellite and it
may just not be visible from from where
we are for a while correct
that's not a plausible answer
I was thinking about the plank
well anyway
oh see
okay
that's interesting the quotes the next
rise time even though
well you're looking at the deep space
probe by default um you want to click
the second assumption if you want the
satellite or something but it's down
there
I don't know those times what how can we
have a
what what does it mean to okay
funky
it's a really Crazy Ore because it's
already orbiting a LaGrange point
so it's really bizarre
well that's a little weird that that's
what we do with it but we say it's both
a satellite because it is in Earth orbit
right
yeah if it orbits yeah it's it's kind of
it's it's kind of a an odd an oddball
yeah if it orbits the earth and it has a
tle then it ends up in Satellite data or
semi-automated feed will pick it up
um
but then if you want to see things that
orbit the sun it ends up in deep space
probe data and this is kind of in a
weird in between
domain
um yes
okay okay
I mean
I think you should talk to I mean maybe
there's something better we can do with
those assumptions for this case
um
think about it okay because I think this
is just very confusing
and I don't even know what space
exploration topic is I think that should
be removed
probably what the heck is that
it's
probably yeah it's probably a legacy
leftover of some you know future like
the jwst was was you know was
under construction but God knows how
many years right
just remove it it's a bug I'll talk to
Dorothy or whoever maintains I'm not
even sure who maintains those oh I have
to look into it remove it it's a bug
um
okay all right
uh well good stuff nothing else
no I don't think so
great all right see you guys soon see
you bye for now thank you bye